dans ce quartier juif ultra orthodoxe
la police est accueilli par des feux de
poubelles des jets de projectiles et les
protestations de manifestants ces
habitants de méa shéarim refuse les
restrictions sanitaires mises en place
par le gouvernement des mesures que la
police tente de faire respecter
parmi elles la fermeture de la synagogue
la police continue de patrouiller afin
d'appliquer les lois et la régulation
liés aux kobe 19
chaque fois que de grandes
manifestations et les galons lieu nous
dispersons les gens nous avons eu
affaire à plusieurs funérailles où des
milliers de personnes étaient
rassemblées notre objectif est
d'empêcher la propagation du comique 19
au sein des communautés ultra
religieuses à travers le pays alors
qu'elles ne représentent que 10% de la
population du pays
la communauté juive ultra orthodoxe est
celle qui compte le plus de cas de
contamination pourtant ses membres ne
comprennent pas les restrictions
sanitaires et se sont pris pour cible je
pense qu'en vérité tout le monde veut
vraiment vaincre ce virus de la bonne
manière et en faisant ce qu'il faut je
n'ai rencontré aucun juif religieux qui
dit nous voulons être malade et nous
voulons attrapé le virus protestation
également de l'opposition les
restrictions liées aux rassemblements
sont ignorés pour pouvoir manifester
contre le premier ministre benyamin
nétanyahou en cause la gestion sanitaire
et économique de la conduit mais aussi
son procès pour corruption
c'est bien sûr netanyahu utilisent cette
crise pour conserver son siège pour
éviter ce procès et nous avons peur
qu'ils soient en train d'essayer de
créer une guerre civile entre nous il
augmente certainement la haine entre
l'israélien l'israëlien de droite et de
gauche ont commencé à se détester
mutuellement
c'est vraiment dangereux c'est quelqu'un
de dangereux pour nous je pense que
pendant quatre ans nous avons eu en dix
villes et tania ou un premier ministre
qui ne devrait pas être ici parce qu'ils
volent notre démocratie c'est un voleur
est un criminel
les manifestations contre benyamin
nétanyahou au lieu chaque semaine depuis
le mois de juillet les accusations de
corruption sont rejetées par le premier
ministre dont le procès est toujours en
cours
[Applaudissements]